anibal starts against the baltimore ball
club
for the seventh time in his career
santander from the left side rips it
into center
field and it's past the center fielder
robles santander hustles into second and
he'll hang there
so another hard hit ball orioles coming
out swinging tonight here's iglesias
379 on the year
to left field get down fair ball
santander scores iglesias
into second with an rbi double well it's
so real offense is picking up right
where it left off
last night 11 hits last night eight of
them extra base hits it
they will take their swings off of him
tommy malone the veteran left-hander he
had an outstanding start his last
timeout against the raise
his first at bat right here that's well
hit by castro he was reaching for it
it's still going
and at the base of the wall he's going
to have to hustle into second
goes in standing up
[Applause]
bounces this one that's a fair ball down
the right field corner
ruiz around second he'll get to third
eaton with a big arm
fires to second but the throw wide and
davis is in with a double
well the orioles continue to be
aggressive on the first pitch that's the
fourth uriel to oriole to attack
the first pitcher the orioles have not
been good in this situational hitting
let's see what
hayes does and jumps on the first pitch
he'll do something about it
base hit into left field davis gets to
third
ruiz scores and the orioles lead it two
nothing what pitch did hayes swing at
the first one i think we're seeing a
little bit of a theme here
first pitch hunting this oriole offense
is rolling so far tonight berto no
surprise there
[Applause]
bouncing ball to short they get one at
second back to first not in time and
it's an rbi
as chris davis scores to make it three
nothing
breaking ball looped into left center
alberto
checks up at third base and the orioles
have runners on the corner
so two base hits tonight for jose
iglesias
full count pitch way outside and down
low
and the bags are loaded sanchez is
having a tough go of it
yeah just simply hasn't found his rhythm
that was a frisbee it was diving it was
starting
magic mountain visit there it is first
of the year
02 kibum and he whiffs and another
breaking ball from malone
set down strikeout number two for malone
this afternoon he goes back to back
whatever you're doing just keep doing it
and there's a shot into the left field
corner it'll get to the wall
answer alberto for extra bases
stand up double for him
that's allowed out to center it kind of
freezes row blaze they're going to send
the runner
and it's short hop suzuki he could only
knock it down
the orioles lead four nothing and
iglesias ends up at second
alberto took off like there was two outs
there and this wasn't
for sure dropping so crack of the bat he
just takes off
it's four to nothing another hard hit
baseball by jose glaciers here tonight
all hit hard into right field base hit
second hit of the night before sondheim
dare and that's going to do it for
anibal tonight
ryan harper none of the current orioles
faced him when he was with
minnesota last year looper
it's down and iglesias has a four hit
night
on the third goes santander can't get
him out four trips to the plate
four base hits sixth game with four hits
in his career that ties a career high
well maybe nunez
glad that sanchez is gone because in
three at-bats he had a walk and two
strikeouts
two big pieces oh hit well way back
and that ball is out of here in the
bullpen
a three run shot for renato nunez who is
white hot
two homers last night and now that three
run bomb
well you can throw that inherited stat
out the window now
five home runs this season that one off
the bat it was a no
doubter 105 traveled 413 feet
and that is now five home runs for
renato nunez in his last
seven games one and one to dwight smith
and now he's got a hit up and down the
lineup that's his first hit he had to
walk earlier
and smith into second with a double
and now severino is going to chop one
the other way
he's heading for second it's eight to
nothing
four consecutive hits three of them
extra bases given up by harper
wanderswell now will take over in the
top of the seventh
he's two hits in rbi that's well hit
center field
robles won't get that one short hops the
wall hayes digging hard for third
he'll hold him up with nobody down
runners on second and third as hancer
alberto
gets his second double of the game
alberto with an rbi severino
and hayes hit down to first base
kendrick flips it to the pitcher
run scores and the orioles add another
one and go up nine to nothing
square already 1-1 pitch
breaking ball to center field
robles back makes the grab
and that'll get in another run so he
didn't get a hit that time just an rbi
and the lead is now 10 to nothing
another shot into left field
[Applause]
nunez trots home and the merry ground
keeps going round and round
severino's second rbi of the game looks
like bp
man big time another ball hit on the
barrel the nets have
not been able to break through it'll be
another inning for right-handed david
hess
no runs four hits one error and five
left
defoe fly ball to right should do it yes
cedric mullins with the nice running
catch
and the orioles drop a shot out on the
nationals
with a big 11 nothing win